Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
We had mentioned before regarding
repentance. The statement of
at the beginning of this chapter that
the conditions for repentance are three
conditions.
He mentioned that a person is contrite
and has regret. That a person
immediately ceases the act that they are
repenting from. And number three, that
the person has the sincere intention
never to return to that sin that they
are repenting from.
We also mentioned that other scholars
number the conditions of repentance as
five
those three
and they add two conditions of
intention that a person's intention is
for the sake of Allah that they're not
repenting from that sin for any other
reason.
And number two, that repentance
take place that they repent during a
time when repentance is accepted.
We then mentioned that repentance is
accepted any time in a person's life
until one of two things happens.
Either their soul is being taken out of
their body
or the sun rises from the west.
The question that we have today,
why is it that we find this occurs?
When we read the books of the
scholarship of Islam,
we see one will mention three conditions
for instance and another will mention
five.
Why is that? Why does that happen?
Is it does that mean that the Quran and
Sunnah are not clear?
Does that mean that the Quran and Sunnah
are unintelligible?
Does that mean that there is a
difference in the Quran and Sunnah? Does
that mean that there is a difference in
understanding them?
None of these things are the reason.
When scholars differ on things like
this,
most of the time, not always, but most
of the time it is a categorization
issue.
What does that mean, a categorization
issue? For instance,
if a scholar says
one of the conditions of repentance is
that a person have the intention of
repenting for the sake of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala. Any act of worship
that is done without total sincerity to
Allah is considered void. We know this.
This is the meaning in practice ofahill.
What is the meaning ofahillah in
practice?
That every act of worship be done
sincerely and entirely for the sake of
Allah.
When some scholars mention that as a
as a condition on its own and others
in Noah do not mention it. Do they
really differ on that being a condition
of repentance? No,
they do not differ on that being a
prerequisite.
However, and Noah would say, well,
technically,
technically speaking,
a person cannot be truly regretful
and truly have the intention never to do
it in the future
unless they were doing it for the sake
of Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
So really those conditions include
the condition of
intentions.
And what about the
issue of repenting during the time when
repentance is accepted?
Some scholars say this is a fifth and
final condition
that if you want to repent, a fifth
condition of repentance is that your
repentance be in a time when repentance
is accepted.
and Neoi and those scholars that are of
the view that it is three conditions
they would rebuttal and say well
technically
this is not a condition
these two times would be considered
what is
meaning when is repentance accepted all
the time
it is easier to mention and it is more
reasonable to mention the times when
repentance is not accepted than it is to
mention the time when repentance is
accepted.
That means that
a person's time is mostly spent during a
time when repentance is accepted.
Therefore, when repentance is not
accepted, this is not a condition of
repentance. This is a manner
of repentance. Meaning naturally, the
natural course of things, the majority
of a person's life in this world,
repentance is accepted until one of
these two events occurs. Being that
these are events that occur, that means
that these are things that bar a
person's repentance rather than being a
time when repentance is accepted.
So we see that these two opinions,
they're really what they're saying the
same thing. They're just saying them in
a different way, using different terms.
And that goes back to what the precision
of knowledge and words and
categorization.
And that precision is desperately
needed. Why? Because other rulings of
Islam are going to be built based on how
that categorization
is put in place and structured.
However, at the final practical level,
when it comes to you or I repenting,
all of those things have to be included.
Whether we were to say the conditions of
repentance are three or the conditions
of repentance are five. Sometimes
scholars will choose a more
a more comprehensive opinion when
teaching especially the general masses
of people. Why? Because it's more
comprehensive.
for instance, the conditions
ofahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah.
For those who haven't heard of this
before many of us might actually be a
little bit surprised
when we say the conditions ofahillah
every act of worship in Islam has
conditions, pillars and obligations.
Every act of worship
salah has conditions,
it has pillars, has obligations. Fasting
has conditions, pillars, obligation,
zaki,
etc. Any act of worship has conditions,
pillars and obligations. what it is
structured by and what are necessary
ingredients for it to be accepted by
Allah
is the greatest act of worship. It is
what we were created for. And all of
this that we're doing
salah zak
is all just what is all just an
embodiment of the implications
ofahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahahillah
it's just sayingahillahill
in different ways saying it with our
body saying it with our wealth saying it
with what we do not put into our body
saying it what with what we do with our
body all of it is essentially saying
And soahill
of course has conditions. It has
pillars. It has obligations.
The conditions ofahillah
are seven. Seven conditions.
Some scholars mention an eighth
condition.
What's the difference? There is no
difference. They all agree on the
ingredients. They just did they just
differ on what categorization to put the
ingredients in.
And so those who say seven that is more
scholarly
when we look at how it is structured. It
is more precise
when when we look at the opinion of
those who say that the conditions
ofahill are eight conditions. that is
more that is more appropriate
in teaching the general masses of
people. Why? Because it is more it is
more specific for them. It outlines
things that people normally wouldn't
think of on their own.
So repentance
has three conditions
and some scholars say it as five. But as
we'll hear in the next narration
that they all agree on the ingredients,
they just differ on how these
ingredients are categorized.
So in Noah tells us that the conditions
of repentance are three. Number one, a
person is ceases the act that they are
repenting from the sin. They stop doing
it. Number two, they are contrite. They
have regret. Number three, they have the
they have the true intention
with earnesty that they will not return
to doing that sin. Their intention is
never to go back to doing that sin.
He then mentions the narration of
who says that the messenger of Allah
said
he then mentions the narration of
collected by Muslim in which the
messenger of Allah sallall.aii alaihi
wasallam said whoever repents before the
sun rises from its west from its setting
point then Allah will accept his
repentance we see that this is one of
the ingredients the other scholars
mention this it's just that neoi does
not consider this a condition rather he
cons gives it a different categorization
but they agree on all the necessary
components in order for repentance to be
acceptable.
Subhanahu wa tala.
[Silence]
Subhuhammed.
Alhamdulillah.